good morning cansel as you may have
noticed 3d movies are all the rage
and when I say rage in some cases I mean
actual physical literal rage I mean
really isn't there enough 3d in our
lives already almost everything I have
ever known has been three dimensions
being a movie in 2d Fred that just seems
like a novelty to me a little bit of a
change it's refreshing okay okay I
actually do like 3d movies and I like to
go see them with my wife because I like
to go see all movies with my wife
because that's just the kind of couple
that we are and so a little while ago
when I was like Katherine let's go see
Tron on opening night it's gonna be so
fun she was like and I didn't get it cuz
I of course it's not gonna be a great
movie it's gotta be good movies gonna be
fun and gathering for the first time let
it slip that she doesn't like 3d movies
because they give her headache and I was
like wow I did some research and it
turns out that 10% of Americans that's
30 million people speak um firt while
watching 3d movies whether it's nausea
motion sickness or just a headache and
this was a pretty revolutionary
discovery for me so what did I do about
it
well I dragged Katherine to go see Tron
and she watched pirate-style for half
the movie and still got ahead but I did
not ignore the needs of my better half
complete because I know how 3d movies
work and I knew that it would be a
relatively simple thing to create a pair
of glasses that let you watch a 3d movie
in to go to that week I call the company
that manufactures 3d glass no can you
make glasses with the same polarization
in each lens yeah I mean we could but
that would totally ruin the 3d effect by
ruin the effect do you mean that it
would be a crisp clear two-dimensional
image yes excellent I will take 5,000
I'm not kidding I actually did it 2d
glass I am so stylin it's kind of a big
deal for me I had this idea and then I
made it I made my idea real
katherine has watched several movies
with those and with the prototypes and
she says it's wonderful I can't imagine
she's just saying that because she's my
wife and I have to say thanks to all the
people who may help make this real
Winnie at the factory Sam for doing the
web development Karen for design Tim did
a great comic that's up at 2d - glasses
calm my dad as always for doing the
accounting and legal stuff and my
partner dftba records alan and also
chris for helping doing the distribution
and actually getting them to the people
who buy it I'm at a thing John I will
see you on Wednesday
time for the end screen and frequently
asked questions question one where can i
buy them - d - glasses comm special
introductory offer $7.99
pear if you buy two you save $2 will
they work with my 3d television no
probably not I'm sorry but it's a
different technologies that televisions
use will you come on my nationally
syndicated talk show and talk about your
glasses of course yeah absolutely though
I don't like leaving my house so is
their campus gave it in how on earth
does that work well there is a whole
page - tea - glasses gum that explains
it all to you do I have to buy them
online yes you do because it the
internet is where it's at man are you
excited about portal - yes I'm excited
about portal - look it comes out in like
12 hours I will be playing it at
youtube.com slash Hank games the channel
where I'm currently rushing to finish
portal 1 because I want to finish it
before I start portal 2 didn't you
forget to thank someone and your
thank-yous yes I did I forgot to thank
Victor who was instrumental in making
this whole thing happen why did your
lighting change so much to the end
screen because in between when I filmed
these 2 things I went to go see Rio in
the 3d it was awesome beautiful in 3d
but Katherine enjoyed it too because it
was not painful for her because of these